To do this, all we do is add the frequencies in each country belonging to the
different continents. There are 2 students from Canada, 3 from Mexico and 10
from the US. So if we add them, we get 15 students from North America. And
similarly, 4% are from Canada, 6% from Mexico and 20% from the US. So if we add
them, we get 30%. We have 12 students from China, 8 from India, 8 from Japan and
1 from Pakistan. So if we add them, we get 29 students from Asia. 24 plus 16
plus 16 plus 2 is 58. And finally, we have 2 from England, 3 from Germany and 1
from Sweden, making 6 from Europe. 4% plus 6% plus 2% is 12%. So now we have
even more simplified data. While this is interesting and provides new
information, now we can't know how many people are from individual countries
just by looking at this table. Creating this table was convienent because it
gave us fewer categories to look at. Three categories in this case. But we lost
information in the process. In other words, information about specific
countries. When creating frequency distribution tables, there can sometimes be a
trade off between convenience and informativeness. But there's no one right way
of presenting the data. It all depends on what kind of question you want to
answer. In this case, if you want to know how many students are from North
America, organizing it like this is best. But if you want to know how many
students are from India, or other specific countries, organizing it like this is
best. The key is to know how you're going to organize your data, based on the
questions that you want to answer.